moi j'en ai marre des gens qui nous
disent comment il faut s'habiller
comment il faut pas s'habiller si les
gens ont envie de porter un hidjab ils
le portent keith haring diab et unisexe
ils le portent et ce qui m'énerve le
plus c'est que les politiques qui se fût
ce que de ça il s'en fout complètement
du hidjab ils veulent juste faire de la
récupération politique et attiser la
haine franchement moi ça me choque pas
du tout vous n'avez pas débité malte le
sont la non indiens tels ordinaire tous
les mots clés ils sont c'est à dire que
pour vous le hidjab c'est juste un
morceau de tissu bah oui bon eh bien eh
ben non c'est quoi hidjab c'est un
emblème alain poids politique culturelle
et c'est un emblème de séparatistes et
pas juste un morceau qui tue et en quoi
ça vous dérange eh ben ça me dérange
parce que je considère si vous voulez
vous avez le droit et c'est une pensée
qui a tapé sa noblesse que toutes les
cultures ont le même droit qui était en
france et moi je ne pense pas je pense
qu'à une culture française à rome fais
comme les romains laquelle tout le monde
devrait disons s'adapter pas se
conformer de façon autoritaire mais
s'adapter et je vous rappelle qu'en plus
le hidjab à fleury chez nous depuis
trente ans en même temps ça il n'est pas
arrivé comme ça il est il a fleuri sous
la ligne et sciatiques des frères
musulmans de l'islamisation des
quartiers où il ya des femmes en iran
qui sont fouettés parce que elles ne
veulent pas le porter et il n'est pas
arrivé comme ça il arrivait dans le
cadre d'une offensive islamistes qui
nous teste et ils ont raison de nous
tester parce qu'avec des gens comme vous
et par naïveté je veux bien le croire
mais vous vous avez pas on ne sortira
jamais mais vous vous trouvez que la
pause doit taper islamisés n'avait peur
de l'islam c'est comment ça s'appelle
j'ai pas peur de l'islam en club 1 et
ben vous avez le droit de réclamer aux
femmes c'est tout à fait légal d'être
islamophobe j'ai le droit de ce bar j'ai
le droit de ne pas aimer l'islamisation
de notre pays d'accord ensuite en
l'occurrence il ya autre chose dans
cette campagne parce que casquette de
quoi s'agit-il on nous on essaye de nous
marier deux choses inconciliables c'est
à dire en symbole de la différenciation
sexuelle et même de l'intériorité d'un
sexe avec un symbole de
l'indifférenciation donc c'est
complètement c'est évidemment si vous
voulez c'est une blague absurde aucun
homme musulman je vais dire si on est
justement ne va le porter si vous voulez
ça je suis sûr que non mais en fait
c'est toujours la même offensive il
s'agit de nous acclimater agit de nous
dire c'est la diarrhée de la diatribe
qui me après le burkini sur ce rallye
minarets des minarets dans l'est dans la
diatribe classique de madame lévy contre
l'islam moi je suis pour le port du
voile qui est tout à fait ce serait bien
mais votre ailleurs d'ailleurs il est
autorisé en france et c'est légal madame
lévis le port du voile et là je vous ai
dit que les masques et les galas et là
je critique les marques mais là je
trouve que l'initiative est formidable à
m'étonne pas que ces initiatives
inclusive c'est à dire que le voilier se
voit là je rappelle qui est légal et qui
ne couvre pas le visage il est pour tout
le monde c'est le même et je trouve ça
bien au moment où déjà vous êtes vous
trouvez des jeunes femmes musulmanes
sont stigmatisés alors que moi je les
rencontre contrairement à vous et
qu'elle me dise qu'elle est le voile est
bien là je trouve que c'est un signe
d'ouverture à bord que c'est très
étrange rappel et ont d'abord vous ne
savez rien de qui je rends compte et
qu'ils rencontrent pas ça mais tant
mcgraw et bata vous soyez étonné ça vous
fera le plus grand bien l'étonnement est
une sentra
moi ce que tu dis moi je prends un
simple simplement que c'est du buzz à
bombay bien sûr ils se sont renforcés
qui se sont simplement dit rizhao c'est
un mot clé qui va évidemment faire
parler benetton qu'est ce qu'ils font
depuis des années ils font des
polémiques souvenez-vous le curé
qu'embrasser une note souvenez-vous
l'anorexie qui était au bord de l'eau
des portes de la mort malheureusement
qui est décédé quelques temps après et
c'est donc là ils se sont dit que les
gens maîtrisent pas la société c'est le
jardin va prendre déjà pas que sa
cagoule mixte et ben il y aurait pas de
problème alors son ombre maison même
pour dieu que la ville avait pas
justement son celi prévu ce qui débourse
a souhaité oui non c'est parce qu'elle
est la question qu on ne s'est pas posée
je
ne sais pas qui est la 10 e mail ou
gmail ou la polémique il peut être même
pas des questions
dépendra pour moi c'est juste c'est
juste un coup de pub ça et là on est en
train de vie participe bien sûr mais ça
c'est vrai les regrets vous répondre
parce que en réalité vous tapez raison
ils veulent se faire un coup de pub et
je fais des rayons nous y contribuons
mais derrière ça vous savez très bien
que ces boîtes bonhomme se donner une
image inclusive comme a dit gilles
verdez qui d'ailleurs 30 sa mère bio
derrière ya l'idée de nous dire mais
finalement vous voyez bien le hidjab
c'est sympa c'est moderne c'est
inclusive c'est rigolo c'est
transgressif c'est tout ce que vous
voulez et bien moi je vous dis que ça
fait 30 ans s'ils voulaient qu'on se
fait avoir
derrière les campagnes de pub de
benetton par des enfants aussi votre mot
plus dangereuse c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on en est là je ne dis
pas que cette campagne là en soi c'est
dramatique si vous voulez je pense que l
étape sur non plus je vous dis llp
s'entrechoquer des choses